You have a lot of people working
across the country very hard
to educate people in each state
about what they need to do to register,
how they need to vote,
it's really important.
and I thought it might be a nice treat
for some of these
hardworking young people,
but I thought it might be fun
if we surprised a couple of them
with a little Zoom bomb,
and it might lift their spirits right now
because we know they're working so hard.
Would you like to do that?
That sounds like a great idea.
Hopefully after us,
we just have so many people
who don't stay silent
when they're in the face of injustice.
When there are people in
power who are doing wrong.
(bell ringing)
Everybody, excuse me.
I just want to say hello.
Conan O'Brien here,
I know the hard work that you're doing.
I mean, I'm really impressed
with when we all vote.
I wanted to pop in and just very quickly
thank you all for all
the work you're doing,
and we're gonna show this
on my late night program tonight.
I wish you'd cleaned up, some of you.
(laughing)
Would it have killed you to clean up?
I hope this is okay.
I wanted to say hello,
and if you're cool with it,
is it okay I have a friend
who just wanted to say a quick hi,
is that all right?
You just hold on a sec.
Yeah.
Here we go.
(bell rings)
(group exclaims)
Surprise.
Oh my goodness.
(laughing)
What are you guys talking about?
Changing the world.
Mrs. Obama I was telling them,
I wish some of them had
cleaned their rooms.
Wow, wow, wow.
Your rooms look perfectly clean.
I'm looking at everyone.
You guys look like you're doing good.
Hi,
I know that this group
is working really hard
on getting the vote out and doing so much.
There's one woman here
who is about to get out
of her car and do stairs.
Our team's a little bit
out of shape from COVID
being quarantined all this time.
So we have a lot of stairs to make up.
Oh my God. Conan, you need to do that.
What are you talking about?
I mean, what makes you think I'm not
in perfect physical condition, Mrs. Obama?
Your hair is a little too perfect.
It's not look how's that?
Don't you like Conan's
hair, you guys? I mean-
We love Conan's hair.
Thank you very much, I love it
during this incredibly tense time
in historic time in our nation.
We have the former first
lady talking to you guys
who are working so hard
to get the vote out,
and the conversation has gone to my hair.
(laughing)
I think that is absolutely
ridiculous and absurd, Mrs.Obama,
I know she feels the same way I do
that we're just really
grateful to you guys
for doing so much hard work.
Very impressive that you guys are managing
to stay so focused on
getting people registered
and to get them informed.
And you're doing your classes online
and staying involved in your
teams and running stairs.
And you know, I mean, it's just amazing,
but it's work that is so needed.
It is so important for you guys
to get your generation and your peers
and your family members
focused on this election.
The work that you're doing
couldn't be more important
and I'm so proud of you.
And it's like, when I see your faces,
that makes me wanna work harder
because I think you all deserve leadership
that reflects who you all are.
And you guys are good and smart
and kind and open and caring.
And you deserve leadership
that reflects that,
so keep working hard please.
And we love you so much.
Conan aren't they? I mean,
duh.
Conan's speechless-
Yeah. I'm very impressed with these kids.
Again, I think some of the
rooms could be cleaner,
but I'm gonna shut up about it.
Well, thank you all very, very much
and I leave the final
sign off to Mrs. Obama.
Oh, you guys keep up the great work,
study hard, stay safe, wear your masks,
I'm gonna be your mother.
Eat your vegetables,
No. Okay.
and give your families my love
and your classmates.
Tell them to vote, Vote,
vote, vote, vote, vote.
Okay?
Let's have a cheer for Mrs Obama
(all cheering)